[Music]
chapter eight of ursula k le guin's
third earth sea novel the farthest shore
is titled the children of the open sea
and we don't actually get the children
at the very beginning of the chapter
instead aaron and sparrowhawk or gad are
floating in his boat look far he has
been terribly wounded
and things are looking pretty bad and
then they are
rescued fairly
early on there's a description they
stood in the boat three of them
stalked thin and angular great-eyed like
strange dark herons or cranes their
voices were thin like birds voices he
did not understand them
one of them
knelt above him with a dark bladder on
his arm and tipped from it into aaron's
mouth it was water aaron drank avidly
choked drank again until he drained the
container then he looked about and
struggled to his feet saying
where is where is he for in look far
with him were only the three strange
splendor men they've taken ged and he
doesn't know where
get has gone off to or been taken off to
and you'll find out
later that these are very good people
and ged is is slowly healing
the chief had made a decision
to take them in even though they're not
members of this
tribe that that exists out on the open
seas and they have essentially safety
sanctuary and all the things that they
need in order to recover and to be ready
for the rest of their quest
doing that and what do we know about
these people we get to know them over
time for example there's a vignette of
aaron swimming with them and he's been a
decent swimmer in the past but he can't
compare to these kids who swim all the
time right and they suggest swim like
this swim like this try this try this
and so he's sort of like a a child in a
way to them
in part because he comes from
a place where very different skills are
needed these people live
almost the entire
year
on the open sea you could say that their
existence
is on the sea even though they put in to
land
once a year
as the explanation goes to get timber
from this place called long dune and if
you look on the map of earth sea you see
that long dune is
about as far south and as far
west as you're going to get
well as it turns out the ocean extends
even further
to the west and to the south indeed
perhaps all you know in every direction
from earth sea and when aaron asks where
are we the chief simply gestures and
leguin says in sort of a compass going
from north to east and says all the
islands
are there we are
down this way
from these islands and get when he's
asked about it will say these people are
really living off the map this is
further than any of our charts
go and they seem to have a idyllic
dreamlike existence as it turns out
that's because of where they currently
are in the great cycle
of their year they're harvesting a kind
of seaweed they're catching fish they're
eating
as
[Music]
the the narrator is going to say
these people don't measure hours at all
everything is measured in terms of days
and nights there's a very interesting
discussion that takes place in there
that i i would like to
bring up so
he says uh that evening until dark and
all the next long golden day and all the
days that followed aaron swam and talked
and worked with the young people of
starr's raft and
of all the events of his voyage since
that morning of the equinox when he and
sparrowhawk left rope this seemed in
some way the strangest for it had
nothing to do with all that had gone
before
in the voyage or in his life and even
less to do with what was yet to come at
night lying down to sleep among the
others under the stars he thought
it is as if i were dead and this is an
afterlife here in the sunlight beyond
the edge of the world among the sons and
daughters of the sea
and we we find out he says he knew their
life could not always be lived in this
dreamlike ease he asked of winter and
they told them of the long reigns and
mighty swells the single rafts each
separated from the rest drifting and
plunging along through the gray and
darkness week after week after week last
winter in a month-long storm they'd seen
waves so great they were like thunder
clouds they said for they'd not seen
hills
from the back of one wave the next could
be seen immense miles away rushing
hugely towards them could the rafts ride
such such seas he asked and they said
yes but not always
they married very young many babies
crept and toddled among the rafts tied
by long leashes to the forepost of the
central shelter all crawling into it
during the heat of the day and sleeping
and wriggling heaps the older children
tended to the younger men and women
shared in all the work
and
a little bit later
aaron actually
says
he knew now why this tranquil life and
sea and sunlight on the rafts seemed to
him like an afterlife or a dream it was
because he knew in his heart
reality was empty
without life or warmth or color or sound
without meaning there were no heights or
depths all this lovely play of form and
light and color on the sea and in the
eyes of men was no more than that a
playing of illusions on the shallow void
this is when he's talking with
sparrowhawk and he's going to confess to
him that he
betrayed his his trust that he
gave into his fear his [ __ ] his terror
of death
and
sparrowhawk helps him he takes his hand
and then he says aaron's true name
lebanon
laban and this is and thou art
there is no safety and there is no end
the word must be heard in silence there
must be darkness to see the stars the
dance is always danced above the hollow
place above the terrible abyss so get is
not saying oh lebanon take it easy look
at look at these people here how nice
their life is
there's a recognition that death is
always there destruction the abyss is
always
before us but while we have time we can
still
choose we can still
act we can still be what we
are and there's a healing that is taking
place for
lebanon or aaron and for ged sparrowhawk
while they're here with these people a
healing of the body but also a healing
of their spirits that is going to allow
them to deal with the
problems ahead
going back to the location thing there's
this interesting discussion about the
life of these people we've already
mentioned
going to the long dune and what happens
in winter and aaron finds out
that they are not only southeast of all
the islands they're in this this great
path that is being followed
and in the great path
the
people the
children of the open sea are following
the great whales who
they they view as the great ones or the
old ones as a matter of fact they
thought that perhaps ged might be one of
them in disguise so in spring they are
where they currently are in the story on
the roads of uh balatron and they ask
ged and and uh aaron how did you wind up
here in balatron and they're like bala
what i don't know what you're talking
about
this is where they meet together after
the winter and marry and dance and
harvest and join together in all of
their stuff and then they
they go south
further south on the
great current following the old ones in
the summer in the fall as the whales go
back north they travel back north again
to the long dune where they harvest
timber and other things that they need
from the land this is the only time that
they're really going ashore and then in
winter as we've spoken about each of the
rafts goes alone through the grayness
the darkness the great waves the storms
and they survive or they don't and every
year there's a few rafts missing when
they reunite at balachar but they build
new rafts and you know they keep up
their population
through what they do
and they have their own culture
they have their own
you could call it their own dialect of
language because you know they have no
word for hill for example as sparrowhawk
will remark it's it's kind of nice
living with these people but can you
imagine never seeing a pear tree and
blossom or the taste of a running spring
there are things that they simply don't
have words or concepts for
and there's a central question
that's being posed and then being
answered in the next chapter
can the children of the sea
continue in this existence
apart from the other people of earth sea
who clearly are suffering there's
there's a major
problem a crisis that's going on the
equilibrium has been
disequilibrated and magic lock whatever
you want to call it joy in life is
running out of the world can these
people continue on and there's a
discussion here the chief
says i have thought of the things you
have told me how men think to come back
from death into their own bodies and
seeking to do this forget the worship of
the gods and neglect their bodies and go
mad this is an evil matter and a great
folly also i have thought
what does it have to do with us
we have nothing to do with other men
their islands their ways their makings
and unmakings we live on the sea in our
lives or the seas
we do not hope to save them we do not
seek to lose them madness does not come
here we do not come to land nor do the
landfill come to us when i was young we
spoke sometimes with men who came on
boats to the long dune when we were
there to cut the raft logs and build the
winter shelters
often we saw sails from ohio and well y
following the great whales in the autumn
often they followed our rafts from afar
for we know the roads and meeting places
the great ones in the sea but this is
all i ever saw of the land folk and now
they come no longer maybe they've all
gone mad and fought with one another two
years ago on the long dune looking north
to well y we saw for three days the
smoke of a great burning if that were so
what is it to us we are the children of
the open sea
we go the sea's way and so there's
there's a
an idea that maybe they'll escape if all
the rest of earth see crashes and burns
maybe this is the continuance of
humanity
as it turns out they are not so
distantly connected to the rest of earth
sea one prime example of that is the
dance that all of them engage in the
long dance which is held on every aisle
of the archipelago though the steps and
songs may vary and what we find when
they are
engaging in the long dance
the chief asks
why do you cease it's not even daybreak
not dawn and the man stammers and says i
don't know
sing on the chief says the long dance
has not ended
i do not know the words the chanter said
and his voice rose high as if in terror
i cannot sing i have forgotten the song
saying another then
there are no more songs that has ended
the chanter cried and fell forward till
he crouched on the decking and the chief
stared in him at amazement
and
the mage stands up and says the dance
has not ended
nor the night aaron sing aaron would
have said i cannot lord but he drew a
deep breath and sang
and uh before the song was ended the
scan the sky had paled to grayish blue
the chief says that's a good song it
would not be well to end the long dance
before it is completed i will have the
lazy chanters beaten with nigel thongs
and sparrowhawk says comfort them rather
no singer chooses silence so it's clear
that
the same catastrophe that is happening
all across earth sea
to human beings
is happening to these children of the
sea as well
it's not a refuge
it's not a
escape
from
what's occurring universally and so
ged and aaron in
solving this issue at the the end of the
novel we'll be solving it as well for
the children of the open sea but for for
a brief period we get to see this very
interesting
group this very interesting community of
people who
heal and help
the
two people the arc mage
and the young
princeling on their way
you